- [Man] Do you have
some advice for
two 16-year-old entrepreneurs?
- I mean the only
thing that I think maps
for every 16-year-old
entrepreneur is patience.
The biggest mistake a
16-year-old entrepreneurs make
is they want things
to happen too soon.
You have so much time.
It's insane to me to think about
how much time you actually have.
If you doubled your age,
you would still be eight
years younger than me.
You know what I mean?
When you think about it that
way you have so much time.
So I thinkthe biggest thing
I would tell you is
use your advantages.
So you don't have experience
but you have time.
What that means is
put yourself in a position
where you're learning
and leveraging now
not cashing in.
You know?
- [Man] Yeah.
Don't, you don't
need the money yet.
You don't need the fame, yet.
Build the foundational pieces
that will make you successful.
Be patient, spend time around
people that have
been successful.
Go look at different things.
You can commit to seven
years of just learning
and still be young as fuck.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You know?
Time is your asset, so patience.
- [Man] Great, thank you.
- [Gary] Awesome, man.